guinea's new military rulers are on a
charm offensive to attract more public
support
momentum appears to be on their side
and cohesion seems to be growing among
senior commanders about the coup that
ended president alfa candy's 11 year old
at local markets business has picked up
again after sunday's takeover led by
lieutenant canal mamadi dimbuya and
there is optimism about the new rules
we are very happy we are praying for the
new leaders people have been through
hard times we've seen how inflation has
eaten into our earnings many families
have suffered under the previous
government
mining which accounts for most of
guinea's revenue has resumed as air and
land borders have reopened
political commentators though believe
faces from the past will dash hopes of
change in a country where poverty is
overwhelming despite vast mineral wealth
these are people that we are serving
in the land
and the general lands and arch
government and today they find
themselves in the alpha condesce
government and they want to still find
themselves in this mamadi government so
i want to make a personal plea with him
to be very careful to be steadfast to be
very strong in resisting these people
still guinness political opposition sees
the course an opportunity for a fresh
start much of the support for the
military takeover comes from the
opposition there is a huge sense of
relief here the co-leaders have now
released dozens of political detainees
and a security code put in place in
opposition areas has been lifted
the next few days and weeks will be
critical on wednesday a virtual summit
of the west african regional block
echoes
is expected to lay the ground rules for
the return to democracy
we don't expect them to delay putting in
place an inclusive transition government
to take us out of this situation the
coup leaders created although they have
corrected a situation that was not
normal
the fate of the post president alfa
conde isn't known the united nations the
african union
and echoes all want him released many
hope wednesday's echo summit will at
least start a path back to democratic
rule but with their position
consolidated for now guinness new rulers
may only be willing to make a few
concessions ahmadi greece al jazeera
conacry